kids with ADD and kids with asthma and adults with migraine headaches and other skin conditions
and asthma and chronic fatigue. And I knew that lab work was the secret. With the lab work,
you could sort it out. Welcome everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's
till another Conner's clinic live podcast. Very special guest today. Reed Davis out of
sunny California. And Reed is going to talk about his functional diagnostic nutrition. His whole
program that he has in training, he's trained 4,000 plus practitioners on how to read lab work,
how to use diagnostic laboratory in their practice. And you know what his beliefs are with nutrition
and diet. We want to dig right into this. Reed, let's tell us a little bit about yourself.
Hey, thanks so much Dr. Conner's. It's a pleasure to be here and really admire what you're doing.
Clinics are well-needed whether they're actually seeing patients or clients live or working
online these days. The world needs a lot of help. There's so much illness and I would say most
of it's unnecessary. It's just people really aren't taught the right things. I'll give you a bit
about my background. It might be helpful. So I was in the 90s in environmental law. That's my
actual post-curred was save in the planet. You know, air purge, water trees, bees. And around the turn
of the century, you know, it's getting older and the world wasn't getting any less polluted.
And I'm observing all of this sort of death and destruction environmentally speaking.
I'm not a doomsayer and I'm a pretty positive person, but you know, let's be honest that there's
a lot of crap being dumped on us. And around the turn of the century, I decided to get away from
the environment and work more with people. I started talking with my son's chiropractor,
who had a wellness center in Southern California with a multi-discipline and, you know, a nice center
where I was taking my athletic son. And man, we hit it off. I just started thinking, I really
want to work in this area helping people. And the good news, well, I had a lot to learn. I had nothing
to unlearn. You know, I hadn't been trained in any one particular discipline. I was able to take
a fresh look at wellness and illness and what's going on with people. And it was really just
was an amazing journey. I'll just kind of summarize a bit and say that what I noticed right away,
she gave me a job. Anything you want to do here to help people, let's see where it goes. Who was that?
Who was that? Her name was Leilani Videlis. She was a chiropractor. And she was had a wellness
print. You know, chiroprctors can do just nicks and backs or they can do wellness, you know,
where and so that's what I became responsible for there was the wellness aspects. She was a great
chiro and that's needed. And I became the guy that was running lab work. I just immediately jumped
into some training and some programs and things. But more importantly, she said you can work on my
patients in between your classes, taking functional lab work and all these different things. So I just
got more experience than anybody. It turns out that after several years, I was told you run more
labs than any five doctors we know. I was surprised. I didn't know anything. You know, I was just
working hard because I liked helping people and I was having fun. You know, Thomas Edison,
famous inventor, said I never worked a day in my life. And that was kind of like me. I was working
really hard, you know, long hours and many, many days, no vacations for years. But I just loved it.
I loved helping people and figuring things out. I'm a great researcher and writer. And so
after years and years, we're just running thousands of labs and thousands of people. For anything
that ailed them, I started recognizing patterns in these functional lab tests. And I could just tell
you real quickly, H-I-D-D-E, and it spells hidden. And it looks for hidden. I call them healing
opportunities. So not medical diagnosis. Nobody wanted any parts of that around our office.
Heck, everyone had been to four or five doctors already or 10. And weren't better yet. So they were
looking for something alternative. And if they landed in front of me, I was going to run lab work,
like saliva testing, urine testing, stool testing, and some blood testing. But the alternative
labs of the day, now it's called functional medicine. But I was there in the beginning when it was
kind of sorcery, you know, like, like, you know, alternative medicine went to complimentary,
complimentary became integrative, integrative is now functional or lifestyle medicine. But way back
then, it was cutting edge. And I pioneered, and I ran thousands of labs, thousands of people,
recognized some patterns. And so I've been teaching those patterns for many years now.
What did you transition to teaching doctors and practitioners?
Yeah, in 2008, you know, I started there in 1999, 1989. My son was, again, going there,
he was a great high school athlete and you get banged up. And I was very interested in the whole
field of helping people instead of the planet. Like I said, I was an environmental
business. And I switched gears. I just said, I'm going to help people. So the transition was
from researching lakes and rivers and air and bodies of water. And also a lot of the laws
involved around recycling and anti-pollution and things like that. I just started working
with people. I just knew I could figure something out. So I was taught by the doctors there
and but mostly my own observations. The sheer volume of work, Dr. Connors, was incredible. I didn't
know it. I didn't know I was doing anything special till they told me. And then they kept saying,
you need to be teaching others. The system that I created, we now call it functional diagnostic
nutrition. It's just the name for the methodology that evolved after 10 years. And so then they just
encourage me to teach others what you're doing. And even my clients are patients. You should be
teaching. You should be teaching. Anyway, I'm not playing the word reluctant hero or anything
like that. I just didn't know how to teach. I said, okay, well, I'll put together a workshop
and the rest is history, man. Everyone loved that workshop. And it's now become this big.
I've 40 people working for me now. Back then it was just me. I was just trying to develop a system
that worked for our patients. That's all I cared about. Our patients, can I make them better? We're
very busy. Great, great business, great clinic. But when I started teaching it, just think of the
people, you multiply the number of people that you're actually helping. That's the whole point thing.
Yeah. So your system, you know, teaching 4,000 plus practitioners, that's a giant step there.
And then you talk about how many patients those practitioners have. Yeah. How many people you're
really helping. Give us some of your key things, what you found with patients that did not have
success at other clinics. I'm sure there's a lot. But maybe some of the couple big ones at
point that you jump out at you, things that you found. Well, early on, because I mentioned a pattern
that I recognized. But early on, I just started having, you know, they say if you work hard enough
long enough, you start having good luck. So I kept having some really good success with certain
types of patients. Lady was coming in for chiropractic and some acupuncture and stuff.
And I was just walking her back to the room one day, treatment room. We had a big clinic. And
I recognized she was down. I said, Hey, what's going on? Oh, I'm just so upset. This 40 pounds.
I could see it in her face, the 40 pounds she was overweight. And it was just killing her.
And she said, it's only been two years since I've been on this medication for the hives.
She was on some kind of medication for the hives for two years. And it made her gain 40 pounds. And
before I could get a word out of my mouth, she goes, and you know, I was at the, she was really frustrated
this day. She said she had just been to the doctor and complain of the 40 pounds. And according to
her, he said, you could be fat or you could have the hives take your pick. And she said, well,
that's really depressing. He said, according to her, well, I can write your prescription for
antidepressants if you'd like. Oh, yeah, that's the game. So when I said to her, finally, I got a word
in it. And I said, well, did you ever try to find out why you get the hives? And man, her head
did an exercise. Like what? I said, yeah, try to find out why what was giving you the high. It never
had occurred to her or her physician, any of her other practitioners to just run some labs,
which we were doing routinely. And long story short, after we got her test results back,
changed her diet and some environmental things, household cleaning products and personal care
products. And just cleaned up her environment, so to speak. Guess what? Within 90s, she was off
from medication and didn't get the hives. Yeah. And so it was so life changing way over 20s.
And experiences like that over and over and over. Kids with ADD and kids with asthma and adults with
migraine headaches and other skin conditions and asthma and chronic fatigue. And you just name it.
I mean, just so many people were just completely changed. I knew that lab work was the secret.
And again, this pattern was emerging of hormones, immune, digestion, detoxification,
energy production and nervous system balance, the sympathetic period. So those six,
now it took a long time. I didn't discover that overnight, but that pattern just kept re-emerging in
every patient that came in with chronic downward spiraling stress-related conditions. So their
life's overwhelming. And it's the environment and it's their diet and they're not actually, it's
everything going on. We call it the epi genetics, not their genetics, but you look at the epi genetics.
And you can with the lab work, you can sort it out. So I know you'll like this, Dr. Connors,
the the labs I ran with saliva, urine, blood, stool. We checked their hormones with saliva,
including the cortisol and the HCA and the circadian rhythm and their sex hormones looking at
melatonin, even secretory HCA, which now you're getting a peek into the immune system. So you're seeing
stress has affected their immune system. It's down, then they get the dysbiosis in the gut,
because their immune system is off. The bad back here. Well, now you're not breaking down protein.
Very well. Things are going not being assimilated. So now you've got protein, amino acid,
neurotransmitter problems. So you start off with stress. Those are the sex hormones off. That's
the symptoms. Your body's breaking down. Your catabolic. So your immune system starts to take
a dump. Now you got dysbiosis. You got digestive issues and all kinds of rabbit holes that could
take it. Then finally, the bigger box bacteria overgrowth in SIBO parasites, funguses, biofilms.
These things still start to interplay, and you get leaky gut. Now you've got hyperperperperum,
now you've got anitins and immune complexes going into the humoral bloodstream and clogging up the
liver and just thinking to place up, right? So those are just a few avenues where I'd say, look above
all of the symptoms. All of the symptoms that could be caused. Above it all are these healing
opportunities. Some of them very far removed from where the problem appears to be showing up.
So no one's looking. So I learned to look. Make sure you cover this. Again, I call it the
constellation of healing opportunities and those are all having an effect upon each other. So root
cause, people say I get to the root cause. Well, there isn't one. There's multiple and they're
affecting each other in ways that can't be singly measured. So what you have is the term I came
up with is metabolic chaos and everybody walking into a door was kind of metabolic chaos. Multiple
causal, multiple symptoms, sets and things like that. So I became just really determined to run
these five, six labs and every person, some questionnaires and things. And then get them out of
different life to completely change or modify to some extent depending on the person, their diet,
their rest, their exercise, their stress management and their supplementation. Now that spills
dress, D-R-E-S-S. So you look for the healing opportunities, H-I-D-D-E-N,
and then you apply the principles of healing that are in that dress program. And people just
were getting better, left and right. They're fibromyalgia, they're chronic fatigue, they're migraines,
they're skin conditions. And then when you do all that, they can start to lose weight. We weren't
weight management or weight loss program, but everyone sort of starts to normalize their weight.
Like that lady with the hives, man, she was peeling it off like crazy. Now that she could exercise
and take hot showers, which she hadn't done two years, you know. And man, did it change lives?
Well, you see so many people stuck in the medical system where they're just taking another drug
to offset the side effects of the last drug. And it's just a it's just a negative cycle that is.
Yeah, you're so right. We say those people have their ladder against the wrong wall.
Yeah, like if you're if you have a chronic degenerative kind of downward spiraling condition,
your body's catabolic, you're breaking down. All those things are going to need work, hormone immune
digestion detoxification. They only work. They only need some cleaning up. And you can't do that
by diagnosing one problem. Oh, you're hypothyroid. Here's your medication. That system just doesn't work
anymore. Right. What's going on today? Yeah. What kind of things do you recognize that your
practitioners, the walls that they rot into? Well, everyone they know sick and got some kind of
problem and is frustrated by the standard medicine pills and surgery, you know, just aren't again,
the latter your ladders on the wrong wall if you want to get well going to a physician for drugs
possibly surgery, you know, just taking care of the symptoms or managing the disease process
won't get you to the state of health that you want to get to. You got to get your ladder on a
different wall and start climbing. No one said it wasn't work. The body takes time to heal.
And what I would just sort of want to give doctors credit where do the medical system?
If the downward spiral is so contracted, like if you're dying, you got to go get
out of the woods, you got to go get fixed up, get that life preserver on whatever it is.
In those cases, when the downward spiral is very contracted, then the observations I would make
can't be capitalized on. I'm going to check your hormones, your immune system, digestion,
do you talk, you know, we're going to go through this and we're going to then you know,
teach you to apply principles to heal all of that, reverse the damage. But if you're dying,
that's not we don't, there's no time to capitalize on the innate ability of the body to heal. So
therefore we worked very well with people who have medical conditions. That's between you and your
doctor, manage that so that you can stay alive to do our work, you know, which is the lifestyle.
That's where the habits and the conditioning, sometimes discipline, will power, you know,
that's where that's our backyard. Now I know there's going to be people that listen to this that say,
I can't find a doctor that does this. Do you teach laypeople as well could they go through your course?
Oh, sure, sure. Yeah, I'm not here to sell the course, I'm just saying there's, there's a way,
it starts actually with how you get up and think in the morning, anyone can do that, you know,
believe it or not positive mental attitude and being bank full and in a state of grace and
gratitude is if you started your mornings like that every day, you'd find out a lot. There's a lot of
people who are really dedicated and helpful. I've trained a few like thousands, but that's relatively
small number compared to what's needed. So we're just getting started. We hope our business doubles
this year and I'm in the training business now. I have a training program platform. If 40 people
work for me, we're training all over the course has been expanded so that anyone can take it.
You don't have to be a practitioner. It's helpful if you know a thing or two, most of our
grads have a college degree in anything. They're just older and that they've got a certificate or two
could be a nutrition, personal training could be in raky, you know, energy healing, it could be like
the end we have also obviously a lot of chiropractors and acupuncturists and even some medical doctors
love our stuff. They may still do what they do, but they've put a lot of their staff through my
training so that they're all up together working cohesively. That's the ideal scene right there.
But yeah, I've had lots of people to answer your question. Kevin who
took the program because you're required to work on yourself. Not a training program. You just
learn it and go do it on other people. Now, you learn it by doing it on yourself first. That's
absolutely foundational to what we do. And if that's all you did, it would be worth the price of
admission easily. Well, we're going to have information on your course here. How our listeners can
join your work because I think this is crucial. I think we live at a time where
where you have to be self empowered, you know, you can't just be depended upon some doctor even
if it's a great doctor. You have to learn how to take care of yourself. You really do.
So you're so right. You know, when I first started at the clinic, I was, I ride motorcycles and
I love to get out and enjoy my freedom, you know, and I've always felt that we've never really had a
health problem. And I didn't know what going to see a doctor was like. That's why I was shocked
that people would go to six, eight, or even ten practitioners and weren't better yet. So I'm
out riding my bike in the first thing that struck me was why aren't people in control of their own
health? Like, you know, I just was lucky and never had a problem. But these people with long-term
why are you going to one practitioner after another and accepting lousy results?
Yeah. That helped me form my investigative mentality. I'm going to be the last person they need
to see. That's what I told myself 23 years ago. Well, that's great. Well, thanks for coming
on. I would love to have you back again. Yeah, sure. Information about your program for all our
listeners. I think it's exciting. I think it's I think it's self-empowering. And I think I totally
agree with you. I think what you give over your personal power to another practitioner without you
may be learning from them to take care of yourself. I think you're doing yourself a disservice. So I
really sing with what you're doing. Well, thank you for that. We're going to keep doing it.
And I appreciate that you're in Southern California. Do it all less in a state that is becoming
less free. Yeah, man. You know, thankfully, I live out in the country. So I don't deal with the
traffic and stuff. My wife and I are out here and it's beautiful. I live up on a mountain looking at
a lake. But that's not what most Southern or California is about. I mean, we're kind of like
we're in a separate area. Oh, good. That's great. And it's it is wonderful and freedom in it. But
that's what inspires even initially inspired me to help people, you know, sort of back in the city.
Yeah. Well, thank you again, Raid. I appreciate it. Continue all your work. And I know our listeners
will be excited. Yes, sir. Thank you. And you too. I know you're doing amazing things. So
from one to another, keep up the great work. All right. Bye bye.